anti-regime protests in Iran have
entered their fifth week one Human
Rights group says at least 201
protesters have been killed CBS News has
learned that some protesters are afraid
to go to hospitals and are asking U.S
doctors for help online warning some of
the images you're about to see are
graphic Roxanna saberi reports
on protesters chanting death to the
dictator
are losing their lives even survivors of
scenes like this often struggle to get
help several health care workers inside
Iran tell CBS News many injured
protesters fear going to hospitals
because there some have been detained
is equal to
going to freeze them
prison
yeah I managed to contact this nurse in
Iran who spoke on condition of anonymity
so what happens
when injured protesters need help it's
almost there are dying right now in
their homes because of living
I'm so sorry uh it makes me emotional
many of the Wounded are so desperate
they've sent these photos to a doctor in
New York appealing for home remedies so
a person who's bleeding out of their leg
from like a gunshot wound is just
waiting for my response on on the phone
Dr K Von merhadi says the protesters are
hit by bullets batons and shotgun
pellets that must be really disturbing
to know that these injured patients
can't get help in a hospital the things
I do in a hospital with orders and
nurses I'm doing on Instagram with a
patient's family and hoping that
somebody comes in and help it's just a
horrible situation the nurse and other
health care workers in Iran told CBS
news they've secretly treated
demonstrators in the streets and in
their homes isn't it dangerous for you
to help these people it's dangerous yeah
for everybody
the world she says needs to do something
about this
you know
cheerful
before more lives are lost
for CBS Saturday morning Roxanna severi
London
truly hard to comprehend